[Music]
Jihad is a central duty of every Muslim
it's Arabic for struggle Muslim
theologians have spoken of many things
as jihads the struggle within the soul
defending the Faith from critics
supporting the growth of the faith and
its defense financially and even
migrating to non-muslim lands for the
purpose of propagating Islam but violent
Jihad is a constant of Islamic history
and a central element of Islamic
theology many passages in the Quran and
the sayings of the Islamic Prophet
Muhammad are used by Jihad Warriors
today to justify their actions and to
gain new recruits no major Muslim group
has ever repudiated the doctrines of
armed Jihad the Theology of jihad which
denies unbelievers equality of Rights
and dignity is is available today for
anyone with the will and the means to
bring it to
life in Islamic history and Doctrine
violent Jihad is founded on numerous
verses of the Quran most notably one
known in Islamic theology as the verse
of the sword goes this way then when the
sacred months have passed slay the
idolators wherever you find them take
them captive and besiege them and
prepare for them every Ambush but if
they repent and establish worship and
pay the poor due then leave their way
free Lo Allah is forgiving and merciful
establishing regular worship and paying
the poor due or zakat means essentially
that they will become Muslim as these
are two of the central responsibilities
of every Muslim the authoritative
sources in Sunni Islam the schools of
Sunni Juris Prudence or madb make clear
what Jihad is a Shafi emanu of Islamic
law that was certified in 1991 by the
clerics at alasar University one of the
leading authorities into the Islamic
world as as a reliable guide to Sunni
Orthodoxy stipulates about Jihad that
the caleff makes War upon Jews
Christians and zoroastrians until they
become Muslim or pay the non-muslim pole
tax a hanafi manual of Islamic law
repeats the same injunctions it insists
that people must be called to embrace
Islam before being fought because the
prophet so instructed his commanders
directing them to call the infidels to
the faith however it goes on to say if
the infidels upon receiving the call
neither consent to it nor agree to pay
capitation tax that is the jizya it is
then incumbent upon the Muslims to call
upon Allah for assistance and to make
war upon them because Allah is the
assistant of those who serve him and the
destroyer of his enemies the infidels
and it is necessary to implore his Aid
upon every occasion the prophet moreover
commands us so to do IB Calon a
pioneering historian and philosopher was
also a Maliki legal theorist in his
renowned madima the first work of
historical theory he notes that in the
Muslim Community the holy war is a
religious Duty because of the
universalism of the Muslim Mission and
the obligation to convert everybody to
Islam either by persuasion or by force
in Islam the person in charge of
religious Affairs is concerned with
power politics because Islam he said is
under obligation to gain power over the
Nations the great medieval theorist of
what is commonly known to as radical or
fundamentalist Islam iban Tamia was a
hanbali jurist he directed that since
lawful Warfare is essentially Jihad and
since its aim is that the religion is
Allah's entirely and Allah's word is
uppermost therefore according to all
Muslims those who stand in the way of
this aim must be
fought violent Jihad is a constant of
Islamic history no major Muslim group
has ever repudiated the doctrines of
armed Jihad the Theology of jihad with
all its assumptions about unbelievers
and their lack of Human Rights and
dignity is available today as a
justification for anyone with the will
and the means to bring it to
life